I
I came to sing with the the columbia
alumni singers and it's very much a
piece of my heart being back at home via
haven't been back to campus in 10 years
but it looks great and I'm having a good
time reliving the college days staying
in Carmen hall a lot of guys I haven't
seen in 20 years sometimes you don't
recognize the name but you always know
the face
living in the door was in being a
fireman freshman year and all the dumb
things we did when we thought we were so
mature in New York I thought that you
had to wear black pants on her ass hat
I'm kind of giddy that I've got a little
time to actually talk and that my kids
are having fun and someone else's
problem for a book of it
earlier today I went to electric we
studied the core curriculum and I don't
think that other universities that have
anything like the community is unique
and what I like about it is that even
though I'm not I wasn't here with a
class of nineteen sixty one we have a
lot in common there's definitely a
really unique bond between Columbia
students
you